- [Interviewer] Okay, Alicia.
Alicia, where are you from originally?
- [Alicia] I'm from Houston, Texas.
- [Interviewer] And how long
have you been here in L.A.?
- [Alicia] Seven to eight months.
- [Interviewer] Oh, so you're new here.
- [Alicia] Yes.
- [Interviewer] What brought you out here?
- The things that I was
going through at home,
staying with my mother.
All the way from being
a child, all the way
still up until being an adult.
The things that she keep pretending,
and looking the other way.
That she be allowing to happen
to me.
- [Interviewer] Like what?
Like her first husband,
he kept molesting me as
a child and she knew.
She knew he was doing it,
and wouldn't say nothing.
She knew he was coming in my room.
- [Interviewer] She never stopped him?
She never stopped him,
and she was like, looking the other way.
Pretending like it's not happening,
and I'm her oldest child.
I'm the first born.
A mother is supposed
to protect they child.
- [Interviewer] How old were
you when this was going on?
- Eight years old,
and right to this day
the one that she married,
he's not my real father,
but he's my other sister
and brother's father.
So, my sisters, I had let
them know what was happening
because I didn't want the
same thing to happen to them.
Me being the oldest and trying to be like
a big brother by protecting
them and my two brothers.
They was the last two to be born.
I didn't ever share it with them,
because I didn't want them to change
how they felt towards they father,
because I knew how much they loved him.
But then when he got on his sick bed,
he had already had changed his life,
gave his life to God.
He had asked me to forgive him
for the things that he had done to me,
in fear that I had been
protecting him all these years.
But my mother, that's a
skeleton in her closet.
She let me grow up.
I'm the only one in the
whole family that's ever been
in jail, or smoke cigarettes,
or drink, or drugs.
The rest of my siblings
are totally the opposite.
It's like being the black sheep
of the family,
and my mother,
she belittles me.
She does verbal abuse to me all the time.
Well,
then she remarried another guy,
who's 10 years younger than her.
10 years younger than her,
and my mom and him put me out.
Sometime I would come to
my mother and ask her,
"Could I get a couple of hours of sleep?",
there at they house,
and then when I-
- [Interviewer] They kicked you out?
- My mom and him,
because he asked me if
he could have both of us.
She gives him anything,
he's on everything.
- [Interviewer] Oh, so he
wanted to have sex with you?
- Yeah, my mother is the bread,
and my stepfather,
he gets money, but she lets him do
whatever he want to do with his money.
When I woke up,
the man was laying up.
My mom sleeps in the front living room.
He won't even let my mom
sleep in the bed with him,
so she sleeps in the front living room
and she has her own bedroom.
And she on the couch, she's playing sleep,
'cause whenever he's on any
type of controlled substance,
she's not going to never go to sleep.
She gon' stay up and watch him,
because she feel like he's dangerous then.
But she laid on that couch,
and I laid on the couch across from her,
it was like déjà vu all over again.
When I woke up, this man was
laying butt naked on his back
on the floor,
taking my hand and fumbling with his dick
with my mom on the other
couch, across from me,
while she laid there and
played like she was sleep.
I felt like how I felt all over again,
and then one time my mom let
me come there and go to sleep,
and she told me to go get
in her bed and go to sleep.
And what made me wake up?
He and done came in my mom's room,
and got in the bed with me naked,
and so I came running
out of my mother's room.
Out of her bed,
and curled up like in the
fetus position, on the floor,
on the side of my mom.
And when he did wake up,
he came out my mom's room,
and he had her, the girls
that come to the thigh
the penny girls that come here.
He had on one of them.
They looked like biking shorts
on him, but they wasn't,
but they was my mom's girl...
and it's just how, she never did teach me
about menstruation, or boys, or sex,
or how to cook.
I never will understand that.
She don' put me in every rehab there is
in Houston, Texas. She didn't miss one,
but she act like she
never could understand.
She never attended any
type of family meeting
or group meeting to educate herself
on why I had fell in the
condition that I was in.
When I did get tired of doing drugs,
I grabbed onto the Lord,
because I stayed on the
streets for eight years.
For eight years,
as a hoe, a prostitute, a dopey.
Giving my body up for two dollars.
Sucking dicks for a hit of dope.
You hear me?
My family,
they were so ashamed of me.
It's like they had totally
distanced they self,
and I didn't associate with them
because I felt like I was
an embarrassment to them,
by me being the oldest.
So, one day I said I had
tried all types of drugs,
I decided
to try the Lord.
I started getting in the
habit and practicing,
making it part of my routine every day
to read the Bible in the morning
and then the evening.
To actually do the
instructions in the Bible.
Start helping me to change my life,
and so I stayed clean for 14 years
until I relapsed.
I wasn't going around
people who are doing drugs.
You don't have to relapse
by going back to the old neighborhood,
just being unhappy.
You can have everything you want.
The Lord was blessing me when he said,
"He is your shepherd, you shall not want."
I did not want with nothing,
I just didn't have a man in my life,
and when I did allow
one to come in my life,
I fell in love with,
with the way he was,
with the way he was fucking me.
I always have been old fashioned, antique,
and he was ungodly.
I fell in love with him.
I allowed this man
to beat me all the time
with anything he could get his hands on.
You hear me?
I thought that was love.
I loved him so much too.
I wanted a child for this man.
I ended up having a child with this man.
This man beat me through my
whole nine months of pregnancy.
You hear me?
Eventually,
this man ended up going to
jail after I had my baby.
I had my child,
and he ain't got Pops
because he was a dope dealer,
and I was a hoe, you hear me?
A hoe who gets with
men for money and dope.
You hear me?
When he got popped and went to jail,
our son was seven months old.
While he's in jail,
I had made up my mind to change my life,
and because the baby had
made a difference in my life.
To have the baby, it made
a difference in my life.
- [Interviewer] Is he your only child?
- [Alicia] He's my only child,
I had to be a mother and a daddy.
I never did get on any
type of food stamps.
I never did get on any type
of government assistance.
I didn't put child support
on him or anything,
when I was the mother and dad to my son.
When he came out, our
son was six years old.
He left when he was seven months old.
I had God fully in my life all the way.
I was going to college full-time
at University of Houston.
My major was criminal justice.
I was working full time
for M&M Mars Candy.
They make Snickers, Three Musketeers,
Milky Way, Skittles and Starbursts.
I had done saved my money
up in the apartment,
I had bought me a house.
You hear me? A house.
I had all the bills that a
married couple would have.
Every ride, whatever year it was,
that's what year my ride was.
Let me tell you something about the Lord.
Every time I wanted me
something brand new,
he'd let me get it out the parking lot.
He let my vehicles come
off the showroom floor.
I had him so full in my
life, he was overflowing
my cup with blessings.
For me to be able to work full-time,
go to school full-time,
buying a house, brand new truck,
fixin' the (indistinct).
When I relapsed after
letting that ungodly man,
I know what unequally yoked is now.
When one of us is off into the Lord,
and one of us is not.
I start slacking up in everything
that has something to do with the Lord.
I had him all the way in my life.
After I started falling in love
with a dick.
You hear me? The way
somebody was fucking me,
because I wasn't the type.
After getting off the drugs
and it had beaten my body
up for so many years,
you couldn't get me to
open my legs anymore.
Once I became godly, you couldn't let me.
I wouldn't let nobody touch me.
I wouldn't let no man come in my life,
but outside my me being the oldest
and trying to set an example
for my sisters and brothers,
I allowed that man who I had a baby for
to come back in my life.
After he had been gone all those years.
Child son was six years old.
This is a man who did
not have a relationship
with his own son.
I named my son after him.
He's a junior.
Well, I became the bread, just like her.
My mom is the bread at her house.
I became the bread.
I became the bread
before I even let him,
before he even got out of jail,
because I had brought the
Lord all the way in my life.
You hear me?
The Lord had blessed me with a good job.
He had blessed me with his strength
for me to be able to work full-time,
go to school full-time,
and raise a baby by myself
without any type of government assistance.
For me to be buying a house,
driving a new vehicle with
no help from my family,
or no man.
I give all the credit to
the Lord, you hear me?
I was actually walking.
I know what it's like
to be all the way down,
to when you're sucking
a dick for a hit a dope,
and you let somebody fuck you for $2.
I know what it's like to
be all the way down there.
You hear me?
And I know what it's like
to be all the way up there,
when it's all about the Lord.
When you got him first
every day of your life
for 14 years.
Now, after relapsing, I learned from it,
because everything that the
Lord allowed you to go through,
he expect for you to learn from it.
These are all called
trials and tribulations,
and in the Bible he tells you,
when you go through your
tribulations to be cheerful,
but I learned from them too.
I learned about the unequally yoked.
I learned about not turning
to the family, to turn to a stranger.
I learned what had happened,
if you slack up in everything
that has something to do with the Lord.
You hear me?
He say there'll be two gods,
you gon' love one and despise the other.
Satan is a god, you hear me?
Every decision I always made,
it had to be something that
was pleasing to the Lord
for me not to make any wrong choices.
The privilege that the Lord gives you
is to make your own choices.
He gives you that privilege.
Don't nobody make you do anything.
You can make a healthy choice,
or you can make a fucked up choice.
One or the other.
If something ain't going right,
it's 'cause of the
choices that you've made.
Everyday that I choose to live
without the Lord in my
life now to the fullest,
ain't nothing going to go right from me.
It's going to take the Lord.
I call it a monkey.
I got that monkey back on my back again.
He back on my back, and
I know what I got to do,
but the Lord said,
"Well, how long are you
gonna continue to suffer,
you hear me?", and I said, "Hm,"
and he said, "How long you
gon' keep being foolish?",
and I said, "Well,
you're sure right Lord".
You're sure right, cause being out here
in a state that ain't got no family,
and I ain't ever been here,
and I'm experiencing
things I never dreamed
that I could ever experience
being here in California.
Some of the stuff is just
so overwhelming here.
It's so overwhelming,
(police siren begins)
until I just break down.
It makes you talk to
the Lord. You hear me?
It'll make you talk to the Lord,
because I don't have
nobody, but the Lord here.
And sometimes I'm down,
and sometimes I'm back up,
you hear me?
And the only way I'm gonna stay up
is to continue to build my
relationship with the Lord.
(police siren fades)
My stepfather,
I couldn't take a bath in that house
if my mom had left to go
to the bank or something,
because this man would've
busted in that bathroom.
He took the door knob off the bathroom,
and fixed my bedroom where
it wouldn't lock no more.
That's the only time I had to
worry about him attacking me,
but he was so disrespectful,
and the things that my mom
knew that he was doing that she allowed.
This is the second man she allowed.
I'm somebody who ain't
never had counseling.
I wrote my life story one time
in 100 pages in one of the rehabs,
how my mom knew this man
was coming in to my room.
I could smell the alcohol on his breathe.
How he would climb on top of me.
She didn't do nothing,
but when he get ready to die, I said,
"If daddy don't make it,"
cause I called him daddy.
I said, "If daddy don't make it,
I'm bringing that skeleton
out of the closet,"
because it had been in
the closet for so long.
It had been in the closet for so long,
what she allowed.
That's so bad, when a mother knows
what's happening to her child,
and she don't do nothing.
That's so terrible, you
hear me? That's a monster.
You don't even say the word God
unless you're telling me
I ain't got God in me.
He tried to beat me up with verbal abuse.
I know I don't have to listen
to somebody talk verbal abuse.
She actually does verbal abuse.
I call it jealous spirits, you hear me?
I'm her first born.
She ought to be proud of me,
cause I'm the one who came off the drugs
as a stoned dope fiend.
I'm the only one that
has ever been to college.
My mom made all my clothes,
everything I wore to school
every day, my mom made it.
When her and my dad was together,
she didn't have to work,
but one day when we came home
from school, my mom said,
"Let's pack up everything and go."
So, my dad came home, we was gone.
My mama never did tell us
why we was moving out and leaving daddy,
but I knew it.
I knew it.
It was for her, it was time.
She shouldn't have been
pulling us out of that house
for her to know that her husband
was coming in my bedroom,
messing with me.
She should've been done it.
She should've been done
something about it,
but the other siblings, right to this day,
my brother's and them still don't know.
- [Interviewer] So, your
brothers and sisters
were not molested by any of your fathers,
stepdad or other than that.
Just you?
- No, only me.
I'm the only one with a different father,
and all the rest of them
have the same father,
and all of us have the same mother,
but my mother is not
accepting responsibility
of teaching me the things that
a mother's supposed to teach.
I made it my responsibility
to teach my sister and them
all the things my mom didn't teach me.
Menstruation, sex, boys,
cooking, birth control pills,
trying on bras, and right
to this day, when my niece.
By her not teaching me, she
didn't teach my sister and them.
I didn't sugar coat nothing
to my sister and them.
I stayed real with them.
I let them know things
that they needed to know
as growing up in life,
and when my sister and them had girls,
when they got pregnant and they
had girl babies, guess what?
When they grew up old enough,
I went to the library and I rent the film,
and I showed that film about menstruation
that they show you in school.
I did my nieces the same way,
cause I felt like if my sister and them
didn't learn from my mom,
that they might do they
girls like that and not talk to them,
or tell them about things
they needed to know
as they were being girls growing up,
so I did it with my nieces and nephews.
My nieces and them, and as
far as my nephews and my son,
I always taught my son.
That made me didn't want to
have no more kids, you hear me?
They wouldn't tie my tubes,
because I waited until I was
30 something to have a baby.
I'm the oldest, and I was the last one
to bring a grandchild in the family.
The last one to have a baby.
To be away from them is a relief to them,
but if I was to ever to
grab back onto the Lord,
I would be an ATM machine again to them.
You hear me?
An ATM.
When you love a family member,
I don't care what condition
that they fall in.
You're supposed to love all
of them, the good and the bad.
The Lord don't change on none of us.
He just got his hand out all day long
to the disobedient country and people.
He forgives us for all our sins,
and he remembers no more.
So, in order for me to
grab back on the Lord,
I came right back here.
I never been here, but
the first time I grabbed
onto the Lord, I left Texas
and went to Louisiana.
And when I came back from
Louisiana, I was untouchable.
It's like having on the full armor of God,
Ephesians 6:10-18.
It's this full armor.
Anything that try to come against you,
(indistinct)
so often to the Lord,
til I fell in love with the Lord.
I didn't even want a man in my life,
because the Lord was blessing
me with everything I wanted.
I didn't even need no man.
Then I started fucking that man.
When that man came out after
being locked up all them years.
I said, come set an example.
He tried to raise my son, be
with the father of my child.
Not have this daddy, and
that daddy for this child,
and that daddy for that child,
cause that's how they are.
I'm the only one to have
one child in this family,
and I'm the last one to have a child.
I tried ahead.
I moved around and enjoyed my life
before I had decided to have a baby.
I stayed in Atlanta, Georgia five years.
I ain't have no kids.
First time I ever had a drink of alcohol
was at Red Lobster on my 21st
birthday in Atlanta, Georgia.
A Long Island iced tea.
I got so sick, I'd say
it took me a long time
before I ever had a drink
with some alcohol in it again,
but that was my first time.
- [Interviewer] What is your drug? Crack?
- It's crack.
Crack.
Crack is my drug.
I call it the devil love potion.
It's something that we put in our body,
and our body is his temple.
It's abomination to the
Lord to use crack cocaine,
or any of those drugs,
because all those drugs
don't bring nothing positive in your life.
He tells us in Genesis, he said,
"Go and multiply and be fruitful."
Fruitful is everything that's positive.
You hear me?
Yeah, and the only way a person to say
they happy, you ain't gonna be happy,
you can only get happiness with the Lord.
God is a jealous God.
You ain't finna be happy
and don't serve him.
He not gon' let it go like that.
I learned that.
It's all about him.
That's why he say,
"Come to me for rest, take my yoke."
Them instructions? Man,
them instructions are real.
Them instructions teaches us how to deal
with everything we're going
through on a daily basis,
with these principalities, witchcraft,
these evil spirits that you
can't even see with your eye.
They around us, you hear me?
But I learned the door, and
I'ma grab back onto him again.
And when I grab onto him,
I'm going back to Houston,
and I'ma open me up a business.
It's gon' be called,
"Northwest Side Washatier".
I'm gonna put it in
between both neighborhoods,
where I did all my ho-ing,
all my drugging,
and all my stealing at.
I'm gonna give back to both communities,
because the washatier
that they have to go to
in both them neighborhoods
that I did all that,
all that messing up my life at.
They have to get on the
bus and ride the bus
quite a bit of ways just
to get to the laundromat.
It'll make money year round.
It'll prosper.
We'll put a borderline
right there by the elders.
He talks about the elders in the Bible,
and then you got the projects.
The village, with the women and children.
That's going to help them.
They have a washatier,
right up at the corner.
Right there in the corner,
and it's gonna be right
there in the neighborhood.
I'm gonna give back to the community
that I did so much wrong to.
I did so much wrong doing.
It's where I changed my life,
and then turned it right back upside down.
You hear me?
Turned it right back upside down.
Oh boy, it took one hit.
That man brought that crack in my house.
Why would you bring something in my house,
that had me tore down
for eight years, huh?
You got everything.
He didn't.
I bought him two cars.
Got one to drive to work,
one to drive on the weekend.
He didn't make as much money as I did.
On Father's Day, Mother's
Day, he might give me $150.
On Father's Day?
Shit, I'm finna give you
what I want you want to have.
I'm finna give you $1000,
go do with that what you want.
If it's some rims
that he's been looking at for his car
and he told his best friend,
I'm finna go to his best friend,
and I'm finna have all his friends,
'cause look, I learned how to cook,
because I was cooking seven days a week.
On Thanksgiving, Christmas, and New Years,
everybody finna be in my house,
'cause I keep up the tradition
that my grandmother kept up.
My mom and my aunt, they didn't do it.
But, all three holidays,
and then the 4th of July,
I'm finna be at my dad's house,
the one that was molesting me,
and I'm finna have the whole sky lit up.
I'm finna spend $700 to $800
lighting up the whole sky.
People finna pull off
on the side of the road,
'cause his house set on a half acre.
I said way back,
'cause I forgave him.
I forgave him.
I had to, 'cause if you
don't forgive a person,
the Lord would not forgive you.
He would not.
I had learned all that
in order for the Lord
be blessing me with so many blessings.
The strength that I had
to be able to go to school full-time,
and work full-time, and
raise a baby by myself.
You hear me?
None.
Not no daycare,
not my mama keeping my child.
A baby by myself.
The Lord is almighty.
He's so almighty,
if we just give him a chance,
and I had to hit rock
bottom to learn that.
- [Interviewer] Alright Alicia,
thank you so much for talking to me.
Your story's incredible.
- Thanks a lot for listening to me,
I'm sorry for getting so emotional.
- [Interviewer] No, no. It's fine.
- I appreciate it.
I appreciate it.
- [Interviewer] You probably
don't get a lot of chances
to talk about this, right?
- I'm not gonna share
with too many people,
but I really appreciate it,
that took a lot off of me.
It reminded me
of what I better start
doing while I'm here.
You know, it's like I done forgot
what my purpose is of being here.
And to go through those steps with my life
and say,
"You must've forgotten, how you up here
doing the same mess here again
what you was doing in Houston, Texas.
You done forgot what
your real reason here".
Just sharing it with you,
reminded me of what my real reason is.
- [Interviewer] You've done it before,
you can do it again.
- [Alicia] Yeah, and I thank you for that.
- [Alicia] You really helped me today.
- [Interviewer] I'm
helping you out, right?
(Alicia cries)
- [Alicia] Oh Lord, and baby Jesus.
You took my breath away.
I know I didn't see just one zero.
Oh, oh.
You took my breath away.
Oh, you took my breath away.
Lord have mercy, Jesus.
I'm gonna get my shit
together, you hear me?
I'm gonna straighten up.
Oh, I knew ain't nobody
take my breath away.
I never had anybody that
You took my breath away.
Oh, you took my breath away.
I can't even believe it,
but you took my breath away.
- [Interviewer] It's alright.
- [Alicia] You took my breath away.
- [Interviewer] (indistinct)
- [Alicia] Oh my God,
you took my breath away.
- [Interviewer] Go ahead and sign here.
- [Alicia] I'm gonna take heave.